this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by the Y files operation podcast
deep Dives and longer stories every
week humans are the apex predator not an
apex predator the apex predator there's
no animal on earth that is stronger more
intelligent or more adaptable than Homo
sapiens but telling the human story from
the beginning is difficult it was a time
when two words defined our world fear
and violence it was a time when we were
not the apex predator we were their prey
we emerged from our caves during the day
hoping we wouldn't be hunted by the
monsters in the woods so vicious were
these monsters they still live in our
myths and our nightmares they created a
generational trauma embedded into our
DNA over hundreds of thousands of years
of evolution these creatures were
stronger faster and when it came to
combat more intelligent than we were
it's a miracle any of us are even here
this is the story of how modern humans
conquered the monsters and won the
battle for the world but here's the
thing those fearsome monsters defeated
by humans were other
[Music]
humans until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are
appreciated sir I'm going to need you to
come with us uh
okay
[Music]
hello can anybody hear me I don't know
why I'm here take off the
pillowcase we are agents with the cfp
cfp I I don't know what that is I I
never heard of that yeah that's not your
concern uh okay we have been following
your show and we have reason to believe
hey dude I thought I was going to do the
investigation this time if you're
getting do it then do it stop sitting
there do it all right jeez we have been
following your show and we have reason
to believe that you have far more
information on your topics that you've
been sharing what we have been following
your show no no no I I I heard you I
just I I just don't know what that means
we have been following your show he
speaks English you your question
is confusing my question is not
confusing yeah it he's just playing
you're well if you know that I have more
information then you already know that I
what I know that you know just tell us
what we want to know okay what what what
episode are you talking about what
episode are we talking about I don't
know dude you're you're the researcher
no you're supposed to know this what the
heck the one that has more information
look guys I have a podcast that covers
all of this the yfiles operation podcast
comes out every week on Mondays we
release the YouTube episodes and then on
Wednesdays we do deep dives into those
stories and then we cover unredacted
topics that are a little too sensitive
for you
YouTube kind of makes sense and uh where
does this podcast air uh the wi files
operation podcast you can get it on
Apple Amazon Spotify Pandora anywhere
you listen to podcasts sounds really
convenient actually super smart okay go
unlock his cuffs so can I go me unlock
the Cuffs you have the keys No I gave
you the keys you did not give the keys
specifically
you you give me ke you're the one who
sat on the syringe on everyone L that we
were Men In Black and we're way cooler
than in the movies we are way cooler
than the guys in the movies give me a
little supporter
while
down fine whatever what wait wait where
do he go a damn it not
again you are not who you think you are
well you're human but we Homo sapiens
weren't the first type of humans just
50,000 years ago various species of
humans shared the planet with us at the
same time and they were everywhere
denisovans settled in Russia florensis
traveled all the way to Indonesia
lenensis traveled through Asia and all
the way down through the Philippines and
of course there's us Homo sapiens we
evolved in Africa then moved into the
Arabian Peninsula and spread to other
parts of Asia Australia Europe and the
Americas in time Homo sapiens would
colonize every habitable region on Earth
but that would take thousands of years
because there was something or someone
standing in the way of our progress
another species of human a species of
human that was Stronger Faster and more
adaptable to extreme environments this
fearsome and fearless Warrior species
was the
Neanderthal the Neanderthal was not the
dumb bumbling caveman you were taught in
school they were intelligent had spoken
language they built large family groups
that organized into tribes that then
organized into Villages they conquered
fire they created art they created Music
they created tools but their specialty
was creating
weapons this species of superhuman
Warriors conquered Europe easily they
crossed the English Channel and
conquered Britain the warm coasts of the
Mediterranean 2o were theirs for 500,000
years they devoured Europe the Middle
East and Asia they were the kings of the
world the Ultimate Warriors the apex
predator unlike other human species who
ate mostly fruits seeds and Grains
neanderthals only ate meat they were
strong enough to take on animals that no
other creature would touch Cave Bears
leopards mammoths even rhinos but their
favorite prey their favorite food was
us
[Music]
do you know the names of your great
grandparents what about the names of
their great grandparents I can only
trace my family back a few Generations
royal families and Nobles have records
of their ancestors that go back hundreds
of years some over a thousand the
Chinese philosopher confucious has one
of the world's most extensive family
trees today confucious has millions of
living descendants yeah so does WIIL
Chamberlain documentation of confucius's
family goes back 2500 years even those
people are not who they think they are
2500 years is nothing our story is much
older than that millions of years older
7 million years ago a new primate split
off from chimpanzees this was
sinanthropus
chenis sinanthropus was a new type of
species the first homin hominins include
modern humans extinct human species in
all of our immediate
ancestors modern humans Homo sapiens
emerged about 300,000 years ago so what
about all the time in between were there
humans sure lots of them a million years
after
santhrupthi legs are overrated well
bipedalism exposes less of the body to
the sun which helps with heat regulation
and walking on two legs instead of four
is also much more energy efficient but
the biggest advantage of all it freed up
the hands for carrying objects food and
tools ardipithecus or Arty came next
they definitely walked upright early
humans mostly ate leaves fruits nuts and
seeds but Arty was one of the first
human species to consume meat though it
was rare well I prefer medium rare no it
was rare meaning uncommon ah still early
humans were mostly vegetarian oh really
did they tie the fur and their head into
AP buns maybe Splash on a little pachuli
do some hot Monkey Yoga no they didn't
eat meat because animals were fast or
dangerous usually both eating whatever
was growing on trees and bushes was
easier and much safer bunch of hippie
monkey
snowflakes then comes a different
species a Australopithecus you might
have heard of the ancient homin named
Lucy she was Australopithecus
afarensis a few million years later
paranthropus emerged these humans were
bigger than their ancestors on average
they were about 4 and 1/2 ft tall their
brains were getting larger too
paranthropus was a tough creature
powerful fast muscular they ate fruit
and vegetation too but these hominins
were now strong enough to catch and kill
larger and larger animals which they did
many scientists believe the highquality
nutrients from larger game played a role
in increasing their brain size
paranthropus soon learned that they can
catch even larger game if they banded
together humans were now becoming social
creatures this is where human
development begins to accelerate by
creating social groups it allowed adult
humans to teach skills to their children
their technology was primitive but it
improved with each generation
homohabilis came next and had a much
larger brain almost 700 g they began to
look more like us than Apes they lived
in communities they are the first known
users of stone tools human species were
advancing rapidly at this point next
comes Homo erectus yeah Homo erectus
please don't be a child homo means man
erectus means upright um I already know
and erectus is
upright unless I have too much vodka
that's enough
all right all right all right all right
these jokes are too easy
anyway anyway the uh upright humans had
very large brains they discovered and
harnessed fire they used sophisticated
tools built shelters and lived in
communities they innovated Advanced
hunting techniques like herting
ambushing and setting traps they were
highly adaptable to any climate warm or
cold and so erectus is the first human
species to leave Africa erectus was tall
standing 5' 9 in some even taller wow
that is a biggy Reus please
stop at some point in school a teacher
showed you this chart this is the
evolution of man right wrong sapiens
didn't evolve directly from erectus
erectus launched the species hyob bensis
it was at this point where early humans
learned a new skill a skill that would
help shape the world for future
generations and shapes our world still
this new skill was
violence when hominins evolved from
chimps they weren't much different than
monkeys but over millions of years they
learned to walk on two legs freeing up
their hands their brains grew much
larger allowing them to learn skills
they organized into tribes developed
simple language and were able to pass on
knowledge information and skills to
their offspring H highle bensis branched
off two new species one of those was us
Homo sapiens the other Branch was well
Lord of the Rings did you just say Lord
of the Rings yep from hle bensis came
floresiensis they're commonly called
Hobbits they were about 3 and 1/2 ft
tall and had large hairy flat feet just
like a hobbit and they lived in the sh
uh no these hobbits live deep in the
jungles of Indonesia uh no no you're
thinking of Tom Bombadil no he lived in
the forest Ah that's right can I get
back to this now you shall not I'm just
kidding go ahead for over 200,000 years
several different species of humans Shar
the Earth Hobbits denisovans hyob bensis
homoerectus and quite a few more but
then about 70,000 years ago all human
species started dying out one by one
finally all species of humans went
extinct except for two us and
Neanderthals today most neanderthals are
depicted looking very much like we do a
little shorter a little stockier maybe
they have a larger eyebrow Ridge but for
the most part you'll find picture after
picture of cheerful looking neanderthals
big smiles Rosy Cheeks but there's
evidence that they didn't look human at
all that's where Lord of the Rings comes
into play a new study shows that
neanderthals were real life Orcs And
they were
terrifying huge hulking beasts with
thick fur cat-like eyes and physical
strength far greater than any Homo
Sapien their bones were much heavier
than ours to support their enormous
muscular strength one of the most
characteristic features of the
Neanderthals is the exaggerated
massiveness of their trunk and limb
bones all of the preserved bones suggest
a strength seldom attained by modern
humans a healthy Neanderthal male could
lift an average NFL linebacker over his
head and throw him through the
goalposts their limbs were stocky their
noses were large and Broad their jaws
were designed for eating meat any meat
even each
other's neanderthals were smart
organized and experts at War their
hunting parties became small armies in
close combat a Neanderthal could easily
overpower five or six modern humans no
other species had a chance wherever
neanderthals went all other human
species in the area went extinct except
for us we fled we surrendered our land
to the monsters and retreated but
wherever we went neanderthals followed
neanderthals discovered that we were a
valuable resource our species was useful
to them in two ways one our men were
good for eating and two our women were
good for
[Music]
mating
no time in human history was more
violent than when we share the Earth
with neanderthals if your ancestors were
alive today they describe the most
formidable beings emerging from the
darkness in the dead of night huge
muscles sitting at top a skeleton 25
times more dense than our own their skin
was thick too tough to penetrate with
most arroe heads these creatures evolved
during our last ice age and migrated
from northern Europe their bodies were
covered in black fur their backs were
hunched like a gorilla but they weren't
slow neanderthals were agile much faster
than us despite our smaller size and
lighter weight their broad noses evolved
to give them an extremely sensitive
sense of smell and taste they could
detect our scent for Miles a
neanderthals eyes were enormous sunken
with split pupils like a cat's eyes
allowing them to see extremely well in
the dark like nocturnal monkeys today
who also have split pupils neanderthals
eyes contained a layer of tissue called
tapetum lucidum when you see an animal's
eyes shining at night you're seeing the
reflection of this special tissue it's a
type of night vision light enters the
eye and passes through the retina to
pedum lucidum acts like a mirror and
reflects more light back into the retina
this biological adaptation is seen in
many different animals cats dogs deer
nocturnal birds and many more but not us
we can't see in the dark but
neanderthals
could some psychologists believe this is
why so many people are afraid of the
dark it's a generational trade a defense
mechanism encoded into our DNA after
thousands of years of being hunted at
night but the mouths of Neanderthals
were the most terrifying part of all
their teeth were twice as big as ours
with a bite force that could crush human
bone neanderthals built communities they
developed Technologies used mostly for
hunting hunting was a neanderthals most
important activity a neanderthal size
meant they needed a huge amount of food
their diets were 97% meat each fully
grown adult had to eat more than 4
lounds of Flesh every day to survive and
they didn't care where the meat came
from aside from hunting mammoths rhinos
bison and giant Cave Bears neanderthals
also hunted each other tribes would raid
Villages rival Neanderthal groups would
not only kill their enemies but eat them
as well and there's plenty of evidence
of this fossilized Bones Show clear
signs of Butchery the Neanderthals
favorite food human marrow neanderthals
were so powerful and confident they
hunted and ate cave Lions cave Lions
weighed more than 700 lb our ancestors
didn't go anywhere near big cats but a
cave lion was no match for Neanderthal
same with bears our ancestors ran away
from bears Neanderthals grabbed Spears
and ran toward them and it wouldn't take
long before those Spears were aimed at
[Music]
us around 125,000 years ago our
ancestors settled the levantine region
the levantine is now East Africa Israel
and Western Asia the levantine sites
show our ancestors developing tools
creating jewelry and caring for the sick
they lived in tribes they developed
agriculture they were physically
recognizable as modern humans they were
building a complex structured Society
they were on their way to building an
early
civilization but then something happened
a new Ice Age had arrived this was a
period of Rapid glacial growth the
deserts Advanced and the forests of
Europe disappeared Under Ice as the
climate got colder neanderthals migrated
South their territories were expanding
their hunting grounds were now advancing
into the land occupied by us we were
also dealing with the shifting climate
and our bodies weren't developed to deal
with it we were slender we didn't have
fur or thick skin to protect us from the
cold the Neanderthals bodies were
designed to create heat Homo sapiens are
designed to lose it and instead of
sharing our land with us neanderthals
did what all humans do no matter the
species Dominate and conquer the
Neanderthals had no choice these other
humans these skinny weak hairless
creatures they had to go around 880,000
years ago the human fossil record
started to disappear and things grew
colder most archaeologists attribute the
decline of the human population to
climate change climate change here we go
again just build a nuclear power plant
you this was 80,000 years ago
excuses excuses I I don't think you're
being fair don't make me drop a how dare
you please don't we go to that well a
little too much
[Music]
but humans didn't disappear from the
area because it got cold they
disappeared because they were hunted
fossils of Neanderthal bones are still
found there but no human bones why not
well because
neanderthals ate
[Music]
them you would think that neanderthals
and modern humans being so much alike
would learn to get
along in On the Origin of Species Darwin
says that killing each other is not only
natural behavior it's obvious
competition will generally be most
severe between those forms which are
most related to each other varieties of
the same species having nearly the same
structure Constitution and habits come
into the severest competition with each
other each new variety or species during
formation will press hardest on its
nearest Kindred and exterminate
them and they almost did Neanderthals
hunted Homo sapiens to the point of near
Extinction on multiple occasions we know
this because the genetic variation
within Homo sapiens is the lowest of all
primate species the genetic difference
between human to human no matter your
race or ethnicity is about
0.1% that's how closely related we are
so what does that mean around 880,000
years ago when our species and
Neanderthals were violently competing
for resources we nearly went
extinct but the Neanderthal population
was doing just fine but us Homo sapiens
we were down to 50 people one study says
it could have been as low as 40 that's
it only 40 or 50 people left on earth oh
Bill Gates would have loved this there's
a small group of chimps in West Africa
made up of about 50 individuals they're
all from the same family they have about
twice as much genetic variability
as all humans on average chimpanzees
have a genetic variation of 1.2%
compared to our
0.1% and chimps are our closest
relatives we have such low genetic
variability because we came within
inches of Extinction we had to start
over with just a few dozen families and
here's how it
happened I want you to imagine the world
880,000 years AO ago maybe you're 10 or
11 years old you live in a wooden Hut
with your family your Hut is one of many
maybe 30 in all you live on the shores
of a lake surrounded by a forest in the
morning you're sent to gather fresh
water your father and brothers are up
early to catch small game like birds and
rabbits which they bring back to the
Village your uncle is at the lake with
some other men Gathering shellfish if
they're lucky they'll find a nice fat
turtle your mother and the other women
Butcher and cook the meat there's a
clearing nearby you and the other
children gather fruits and berries you
store them in a cool cave nearby though
nobody's looking you help yourself to a
few
berries you are a key part of a
community your skills are dependent upon
not just by your family but by the rest
of your
tribe for your entire life you've never
gone more than a mile or two away from
your village neither of your parents or
their parents it's a communal existence
simple
peaceful but your favorite part part of
the day is after Sunset a warm fire is
built and the village gathers around to
sing laugh and tell stories late into
the night your favorite stories are the
scary ones the tribal Elders tell Tales
of monsters who lurk in the forest
stealing children who venture too
far A little time goes by now you're in
your teenage years your duties change
maybe you join the hunting party maybe
you help cook or sew maybe you learn the
art of healing through herbal medicine
though your life has changed so much
these past few years the stories stay
the same now it's your own father with
his long Gray beard telling tales of the
monsters in the woods you laugh as the
children cringe in fear as you once did
not so long ago suddenly your father
stops talking and angles his
head he's heard something there's a snap
from the forest nearby a broken Branch
the rustling of dry brush something
heavy is in the woods a it can't be an
animal the fire burns bright and hot
even the biggest predator wouldn't dare
come close then there's more rustling of
brush whatever's making the noise it's
coming closer and it's big and heavy
more branches snap this time from a
different direction there's more than
one from somewhere a woman screams in
Terror everyone around the fire is
frozen trying to locate the sound the
screaming doesn't stop another starts
this time it's a man he sounds like he's
crying for help his screaming suddenly
becomes a gurgling and he goes
quiet the woman's screams are now more
distant she's being carried away you
look at your father and scan the faces
of the men around the fire they're
afraid they grab their Spears which are
always kept close by then you see a
shadow it looks like a man but it's the
biggest man you've ever seen
all your life your village has traded
with and communicated with other
villages in the area these events have
always been peaceful sometimes they were
celebrations none of this made any
sense but then the man took a step
forward toward the light it's no man at
least not a man like you've ever seen
he's not that tall but he's so wide and
muscular he seems unnaturally large his
back is hunched his skin looks thick and
leathery patches of his body are covered
in thick fur he looks right at you and
shows enormous teeth then you realize
he's smiling he's wiping something
sticky off his chin blood his hulking
frame takes slow lumbering steps toward
you he doesn't need to run he knows
he'll catch you it takes a moment to
realize what you're seeing but it
finally clicks the Elders of your tribe
weren't telling Tales to control your
childhood Behavior sometime many many
years ago we'd been here before
out of nowhere a man from your tribe
your uncle charges the creature your
uncle swings a club at the Beast it
Ducks steps to the side grabs your uncle
by his throat and lifts him off the
ground with one hand something this big
shouldn't be able to move this fast
you're Frozen in place as your uncle
dangles in midair arms and legs flailing
the creature squeezes there's an audible
crack it throws your uncle's lifeless
body 20 ft and turns its gaze back on
you then more of these creatures swamp
The Village it's Mayhem violent Mayhem
you're trying not to panic but you're
Frozen in place your father runs past
you toward the chaos wielding his spear
you go to follow but he turns to tell
you no then you see a stone spearhead
emerge from the front of his chest he
wines and looks right at you in his eyes
you can see the anger the fear and the
love you hear him whisper the cave as he
takes his final breath then you
run as you get farther from the village
you still hear the screams but they're
becoming more faint then the screaming
stops you don't dare look over your
shoulder but you can tell by the
reflection of the leaves that the entire
Village your home is on fire everyone
you love everyone you've ever known is
[Music]
gone evidence shows that for over a
100,000 years neanderthals and humans
were at constant War signs of
prehistoric Warfare are easy to spot a
swift powerful Club strike to the head
was a common killing method prehistoric
Homo sapiens often had skull fractures
indicating blunt force trauma
neanderthals had similar injuries a
Parry fracture is another sign of War
Warfare a par fracture is a lower arm
break from deflecting attacks
neanderthals had many instances of
broken arms young Neanderthal males
frequently suffered trauma and death
their average lifespan was about 40
you'd be a village Elder and then
some while some injuries might have
occurred during hunting the patterns
indicate intert triable Warfare this
Warfare was small scale yet intense
marked by prolonged conflict
it primarily involved gorilla style
raids and ambushes with occasional
larger battles War also influences
territorial boundaries there's proof
that neanderthals not only engaged in
war but mastered
it for 100,000 years modern humans tried
to encroach on the enderal land and for
100,000 years humans were held back but
to the victors of War go the spoils when
neanderthals won a battle with humans
the spoils s were gruesome men were
taken as food we know this from fossil
records the fate of human women was
worse neanderthals and humans were
sexually compatible today people of
non-african descent carry about 2% of
Neanderthal DNA people of African
descent also carry some Neanderthal DNA
and you could bet much of it wasn't
placed there by choice it's common
knowledge that neanderthals and humans
interbred but that sounds more
consensual than it was the full story is
that neanderthals hunted us for food
hunted us for fun and hunted us for
sex now there's a lot of evolutionary
evidence of this that's interesting but
it's not very familyfriendly so if you
want to know more ask me during a live
stream but please put the kids to bed
first now the story I told earlier took
place about 80,000 years ago around that
time neanderthals expanded into and
conquered the Middle East and they held
that land for over 30,000 years that is
a long long time this is where the most
recent bottleneck in our genetic
variation occurs Homo sapiens conquered
by neanderthals were knocked down to
maybe even as few as 40 or 50
individuals as our Villages burned our
men were slaughtered everyone else was
enslaved or eaten but a few of us got
away we went High into the mountains
into cave systems we've known for
generations and like that young human
fled to the caves to escape slaughter a
few others did too and this happened all
over the area in previous episodes I've
talked about cave systems like Daren
cuyu and turkey daru is an underground
city capable of housing at least 20,000
people and their livestock for months
maybe even years it's about 300 ft below
Earth's surface and it connects to a
whole series of underground cities
across the area some even bigger than
Daren cuyu link below if you want to
learn more
now for the most part we have no idea
how old these underground Villages and
cities are building them to hide from
the endals makes perfect sense humans
lived in caves in Israel as far back as
210,000 years ago throughout history
we've used these cave systems as a
refuge against attack and we used them
again the last time our species was
hunted to near
Extinction I'd love to tell you a story
about how our ancestors rose up from
these dark murky places beating the
Neanderthals in an epic bloody battle
emerging Victorious as Earth's apex
predator but that's not what happened
when our numbers were the lowest they'd
ever been perhaps one or two tribes a
few scattered individuals God nature the
universe whatever you want to call it
came to our
rescue with fire and
brimstone right around the time
Neanderthal started disappearing from
the fossil record the ground beneath
Italy started
[Music]
shaking the land splintered across an
area of almost 70 square miles the
entire surface of the Earth melted into
the Caldera below which spewed out
enough debris to become the largest
volcanic event in the Mediterranean for
200,000
years known as the campanian IGN bright
eruption it was made up of superheated
gas volcanic ash and lava no one knows
the true extent of its Devastation but
it caused an immediate and Extreme Ice
Age throughout Eastern Europe into Asia
maybe even the whole world the entire
levantine region was engulfed almost
everything The andth Falls needed died
their food suffocated their water was
toxic the dead became food for the
survivors animal species disappeared
overnight the giant buffalo went extinct
The Woolly Mammoth step bison water
buffalo the giant musx giant deer all
gone the cave wolf disappeared most
types of bear all types of elephants
several rodents and many more these
animals also happen to be at the primary
food source for neanderthals I what no
more tasty humans to
eat as the Earth around us burned our
ancestors went deeper underground we
took with us almost 40,000 years of
knowing how to survive the constant
threat of death some neanderthals
survived but their numbers were
dwindling fast but neanderthals could
survive by mating with modern humans
right well wrong nature intervened there
too as you would expect most
interbreeding was male Neanderthal and
female human they were biologically
compatible but not without problems male
hybrid children were often sterile and
couldn't pass on their Neanderthal DNA
only female hybrids could human females
according to studies prefer to mate with
a human male not a neanderthal unless
than the end has
money interbreeding continued but each
generation of hybrids was more human
than
Neanderthal but even though the first
well let's call them interbreeding
events were tragic the results were
positive by adding their DNA to ours we
created stronger immune systems we
became more adaptable to non-african
climates our bodies became stronger and
faster you saying both look at the
958 world
record technically neanderthals are
extinct but that's not entirely true is
it almost everyone on Earth carries a
little bit of Neanderthal with them if
these traits were harmful or made us
weaker natural selection would have
removed them from our genetic pool but
they
didn't neanderthals were vicious
Predators who assaulted and devoured
every animal they found including us but
they were also resilient
so resilient they're with us still and
now we benefit from their resilience so
like it or not neanderthals are here to
stay neanderthals are real but how much
of this story is true well actually a
lot of it most of today's episode comes
from a book by Danny Vini called them
and us how Neanderthal predation created
modern humans it's a great read and I
linked it below I also link to Danny
substack where he summarizes the book
now he makes good arguments but his
research is controversial and it is not
the mainstream view for example the
human population may have been down to
50 in parts of the Middle East but Homo
sapiens were already on islands all
around the world and had been for
thousands of years now when it comes to
the physical description of Neanderthals
what is there to debate we know they had
large eyes because their skulls had huge
socket ET in fact almost everything
about the physicality of Neanderthals
that I presented in this episode is
based on physical evidence from bone and
fossil records almost
everything we don't know for sure if
they had fur but we do know Homo sapiens
are the only primates without thick fur
but we still have a thin layer of it
some people have a thinner layer than
others what's that supposed to mean have
you looked in a mirror you should rename
this channel Journal of a receding
hairline and I think you're exaggerating
I got two words for you Pro
pcia
anyway every animal alive during the Ice
Age had thick fur and no Neanderthal
needles or needle work has ever been
uncovered so either evidence of
Neanderthal clothing is yet to be found
or they really were covered in fur as
suggested in the
book we also know we coexisted with
neanderthals we know we fought them for
100,000 years and we know they spent
most of that time winning but eventually
the tide turned nobody knows for sure
how this happened modern humans were
probably more intelligent than
neanderthals but that's debatable they
had the same sized brain that we do our
eventual Victory could have been a
combination of luck and survival we were
hiding in caves but we weren't Idol we
were intelligent and we were industrious
we knew that if we were going to take
our land back we'd need to innovate
neanderthals were winning they didn't
have to innovate anything so it's
possible that while waiting Planning and
Building our numbers an early human
invented a bow and arrow and other
arranged weapons we were no match for
neanderthals up close but if we could
attack and harass them from a distance
then Retreat to our caves we would have
an
advantage then there was the campanian
IGN bright eruption in Italy you can't
overestimate the power and Devastation
of this
[Music]
eruption there were pyroclastic flows
that were over 3,300 ft high they flowed
over mountains the eruption blasted out
six of these flows all life within 60 Mi
of the crater was destroyed the ground
and water was covered in up to 4T of
volcanic debris in some places debris
has been found as far away as 12200 mi
from the crater and every time
scientists dig up new information on the
eruption it gets bigger and it's overdue
for another eruption if you want me to
do an episode on that let me know but be
warned it's
scary no matter how it all ended for
neanderthals one thing's for sure we
made it with them willingly or otherwise
everything I mentioned about the impact
of their DNA on modern humans is
accurate as far as we
know now as far as neanderthals having
dark skin and dark fur that's doubtful
and debatable we know that fair skin and
blonde hair evolved in Northern Europe
Neanderthal territory there's also a
theory that Neanderthal DNA created
redheads oh is that why they're crazy be
nice that theory is still being debated
what's the debate that crazy no the
theory is being debated it's no Theory
redheads are nuts the Neanderthal Theory
okay okay take it easy I had a bad
experience with a ginger maybe I'm
painting with the too bro a
brush but after all this violence we
have something to celebrate there was no
guarantee home sapiens would rule the
world and we almost didn't but here we
are we made it we are now the apex
predator of our
planet but there is a theory that
neanderthals
survived still vicious still powerful
still covered in hair still lurking in
the dark woods but they evolv to be much
bigger much taller this Theory says
they've become
Bigfoot that's a different
episode
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's eel fish
finb for Homo erectus this has been the
wi files if you had fun or learned
anything do them a favor like subscribe
comment share that stuff really helps us
out and like most topics we cover on the
channel today's is recommended by you so
if there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the Wi files.com
tips and remember the yfiles is also a
podcast twice a week I post deep dives
into the stories we cover here on the
channel I also post episodes that
wouldn't be allowed on the channel it's
called the yfiles operation podcast and
it's available everywhere you get your
podcasts now in case you need more wi
files in your life not everybody does
some people get more than enough but in
case you do check out our Discord there
are thousands of people on there 24/7
and they're into the same weird stuff
that we are it's a great Community it's
a lot of fun and it's free to join now
if you want to know what's going on with
the channel go to the Wi files.com
WE Post our live stream and podcast
schedule and what episodes are coming up
next special thanks to our patrons who
make this channel possible you are the
fuel in the engine you are the heart of
the channel and without you there'd be
no wi files I'm truly grateful that
you're out there now if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon for as little as three
bucks a month you get access to perks
like you see the videos early with no
commercials assuming I get them up on
time you also get access to merch that's
only available to Members Plus you get
two private live streams every week just
for you my camera's on your camera's on
we get to talk together it's nice it's
sweet you'll like it another great way
to support the channel is grab something
from the Wi-Fi store and grab a heish
t-shirt or stick one of your fist in
these fible coffee mugs or get a squeezy
stuffed animal tget Heckle fish talking
doll or place some go Heckle fish cards
while you're drinking out of your fistal
mug having a c game with a squeezy heish
tug and fish style toy that's going to
do it until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh
yeah I play Bia andara 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I was
I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing the like
[Music]
I within another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends feel the crap cat and got stuck
inside M's hole with MK truck I'll being
only to
aw did Stanley curi fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish on Thursday night Wednesday
J through the
night all I ever wanted was to just he
the truth
toat off through the
[Music]
night
wo the M man Sid and the solar Stone
still come to a go the The Secret City
Underground mysterious number stations
Planet Sero to project Star Gate and
where the dark Watchers
[Music]
found a simulation don't you
wor the black Knack at a L it to me so I
can't believe I'm dancing with the fish
heck of fish thday night with j
and the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the feet all through the
night head fish on Thursday night wedn
they J you and
me all through the
night all ever want want to justar the
truth so the time all through
go good love to dance good love to dance
good love to dance good love to dance
good loves to
dance good loves to dance on the dance
ball because she is a camel and camels
love to dance when the feeling is right
on was in
time love
Dan love
[Music]
Dan